[MUSIC PLAYING]
All around us, engineers
are creating materials
whose properties are exactly
tailored to their purpose.
Fiber composites in
pole vaulting poles
are flexible and light,
yet strong enough
not to break while bent.
Sandwich panels
in sailboat hulls
give a lightweight structure
that is stiff and strong.
And alloying elements in metals
can increase the strength
of the metal by
more than 10 times.
Together in 3.032x: Mechanical
Behavior of Materials,
we will explore materials from
the atomic to the continuum
level.
We'll understand why materials
have the properties that they
do and how they
respond to loading.
And you'll see how to apply
this understanding in the design
of engineering materials like
composites and metal alloys.
We'll also take a look beyond
traditional engineering
to look into nature to further
explore the principles that
are the basis for the
way our world works.
Have you ever wondered how
woodpeckers avoid brain injury?
Or how cattails stand so tall?
By exploring these
questions and more,
you'll see the natural
world through the eyes
of an engineer, and you'll
see how engineers design
materials inspired by nature.
I'm Lorna Gibson.
I'm a professor at MIT.
I've been here since 1984.
I study the mechanical behavior
of porous, cellular materials,
things like engineering
honeycombs and foams,
natural materials like wood,
cork, plant leaves and stems
and bone, and medical materials
like tissue engineering
scaffolds.
I also love natural history,
and I'm a bird watcher.
I love using
engineering principles
to understand the natural world.
In this course, I
put these interests
to work to cover the
fundamentals of how materials
deform and fail.
We'll see why some materials
deform instantaneously,
while others deform
gradually over time.
We'll understand why some
materials can undergo
large deformations
while others break
without any visible deformation.
To get the most
out of the subject,
you'll need some background
in physics, calculus,
and chemistry.
By the end of the
course, you'll understand
how materials
deform under forces,
and you'll be able
to predict how
forces applied to objects
translate into internal
stresses that cause failure.
You'll also discover
how engineers
can control and modify
the mechanical properties
of materials, and you'll learn
to appreciate efficient designs
in the natural world.
Join us to explore the
mechanical behavior
of materials and
to see how this can
be used to understand materials
in engineering, nature,
and medicine.
[MUSIC PLAYING]